today we're on our way to pick up a
collection michael wolf costume design
drawings this gentleman is was heir to
Michael Wolf's estate
I met Michael in the summer of 92 I
answered a for rent sign out in the
front of his house and over the 10 years
or so that I was in that house we became
really good friends Michael moved to the
motion picture home in 2002 and when
that happened he made me a trustee to
his state
I am so lucky I didn't toss all this in
the garbage I have no idea what I had
until I started unpacking when i moved i
discovered a manuscript that Michael
wrote in 1983 about his career I open up
another box and I found some sketches
and I could identify the sketches for
what michael had written and his
manuscript and then another box had
photos in it of wardrobe stills and
publicity photos and I was able to start
piecing it all together Michael Wolfe
was at the time the youngest costume
designer to be under contract with a
major Hollywood motion picture studio
and he was also one of the first
designers to get screen credit as a gown
designer a lot of his work was for at
the time a lot of the big big stars like
Ava Gardner Marilyn Monroe gene Simmons
Jane Russell and look at this Maryland
wearing her Levi's the genes that
Michael and the wardrobe department just
didn't look right and she said well no
wonder I just bring my own a my book oh
good point bring a man and we'll look
and so what she brought him in and they
were they work much better than the ones
they spent three weeks on what makes
this collection special is that there's
a progression what's really needed was
to see the pencil and tracing paper
preliminary sketches that are followed
by the color pencil wash watercolor
sketches then the Wardrobe stills of the
star trying on the dress and then PR
photos taken up to a newspaper articles
and magazines that we're saying what I
hit that dress was and then maybe even a
thank you note or a telegram from the
star saying wow I really like the dress
so it's a big progression I'm hoping
that the collection now will come alive
and that being at the academy people
will be able to study it and actually
get to know like a wolf
so we're going to bring everything into
the library give you things up by
collection will take the drawings put
them in acid-free folders and boxes and
then we'll start cataloging taking a
look at things if they need conservation
we will make these materials available
to curators to researchers you just kind
of never know how this material will end
up being used maybe an aspiring
filmmaker will come in and they'll find
something that will inspire them and
that will help them create something
wonderful for you to see on the screen
so I like to think of the libraries
providing a lot of sparks for
inspiration parting with the collection
is really difficult because it's like
losing Michael for the second time you
know michael and i were really good
friends and it's been really fun getting
to know Michael all over again by going
through everything so it's difficult to
give it up but it's a good thing giving
it up I don't feel like I'm really
giving it up I think I'm passing it on
so Michael can continue to live on
you